not going on but there's also much we
don't know at this hour what we do know
is that Venezuela's current government
has done a poor job of providing for its
own people Venezuela has the world's
largest oil reserves yet it remains one
of the most impoverished and the most
dangerous places on the planet that is
beyond dispute everything else is up for
debate with the overthrow of Maduro make
Venezuela a more stable prosperous
country more to the point would it be
good for the United States
lots of people claims know the answer to
that but they don't they have no idea if
recent history is any guide nothing will
turn out as expected few things ever do
but that has not stopped the geniuses in
Washington has not even sold them down
this afternoon on a bipartisan basis
they agreed that the United States ought
to jump immediately face-first into the
Venezuela mess watch Florida senator
Rick Scott explain do you think that our
presence there would make a difference
oh absolutely I was down the Venezuelan
border last Wednesday
this is just pure genocide Maduro is
killing his own citizen is it worth
though however strongly you feels are
losing American men and women to do just
that you know here's what's going to
happen we are in the process if we don't
win today we were gonna have Syria in
this hemisphere so we can either make
sure something happens now or we can
deal with this for decades to come if we
care about families if we care about the
human race if we care about our fellow
worldwide citizens then we've got to
step up and stop this genocide alright
just want to make sure that's clear if
you care about families and you care
about the human race if you want to stop
genocide you will send your children to
Venezuela to fight right now without
even thinking about it without even
weighing the consequences you'll just do
it assuming you're a good person of
course if you don't care about families
or the human race if for some reason you
despise human happiness and support
genocide then you'll want to join
Satan's team and embrace isolationism
the single most immoral of all
worldviews that's what they're telling
you that's what they're demanding you
believe the message received we've heard
it before but before the bombers take
off let's just answer a few quick
questions starting with the most obvious
when was the last time we successfully
meddled in the political life of another
has it ever worked how are those
democracies we set up in Iraq in Libya
and Syria and Afghanistan tonight how
would Venezuela be different please
explain and take your time
next are we prepared for the refugees of
Venezuelan war would inevitably produce
a study by the Brookings Institution
found that collapsed the Venezuelan
government could force 8 million people
to leave that country many of them would
come here lawmakers in this country
proposed giving them temporary protected
status that would let even illegal
arrivals live and work here in effect
permanently as many have before with no
fear of deportation are we prepared for
that are we prepared to absorb millions
of new Venezuelan migrants all of them
great people no question but many with
little education or skills or English
finally how exactly is any of this good
for the United States our sanctions on
Venezuela I've already spiked our gas
prices that hurts our struggling middle
class more than virtually anything we
could do so what's the point of doing
that so our lawmakers can feel like good
people and if they are indeed good
people why do they seem to care more
about Venezuela than they care about
this country the one that they run
they're happy to send our military to
South America at the first sign of chaos
but US troops to our own border to stem
the tide of a hundred thousand uninvited
arrivals a month nowhere they tell us
that's crazy talk so what's the thinking
here